jacques chirac qui avait raté
l'ouverture du salon de l'agriculture
dimanche dernier pour cause de visite en
macédoine a rattrapé son retard ce matin
pendant quatre heures le chef de l'état
s'est promené au milieu des stands une
visite amicale mais surtout symbolique
pour montrer aux agriculteurs français
sa détermination à défendre leurs
intérêts dans les négociations sur la
réforme de la pac roselyne febvre
le terroir et la france bien que chez
nous tout ce qui plaît à jacques chirac
aux aurores ce dimanche matin les
visiteurs étaient déjà là appareil photo
et bras chargés de cadeaux
et comme à son habitude jacques chirac
aura serré une multitude de main
toujours accompagnée d'une même
attention pour chacun
félicitations
d'ordinaire au salon de l'agriculture ce
sont les hommes politiques qui caressent
les agriculteurs dans le sens du poil et
cette fois pour le président de la
république c'était contraire
aux droits
accompagné par le ministre de
l'agriculture jean glavany resté stoïque
durant ce marathon jacques chirac aura
sur son chemin à gurgy td milkshake
frais du fromage du saucisson et du vin
de pays il aura même baptisé des veaux
avec l'instit gérard klein
mais il aura surtout rassurer les
agriculteurs sur les négociations en
cours sur la pac
mais les paysans français peut être
assuré de la détermination
nation celle du gouvernement à défendre
leurs intérêts légitimes qui sont
d'ailleurs les intérêts de la france et
justement cet après midi l'allemagne
annoncé qu'elle acceptait que la pac
reste financé par la communauté
européenne
le salon fermera donc ses portes ce soir
apparemment sous de bons auspices